Je pense que les choix sûrs ne sont pas souvent les
meilleurs choix, il faut prendre des risques,
euh, cela ne me semblait pas être le cas, même si
c'était quelque chose où j'ai
tout vu sur le personnage, sa
complexité à la période de ma vie
où on m'a présenté  l'opportunité
avec des amis qui
partent à l'étranger d'aller à l'université et les gens qui
rencontrent les premières personnes dont ils
tombent amoureux et des groupes d'amitié
et tout ça, c'était quelque chose dans lequel j'étais
vraiment quand nous avons commencé et je le suis toujours,
donc j'ai l'impression que c'était
le  le moment idéal de ma vie pour faire un film
sur cette période de ma vie, tu sais, je veux
dire, tu ne peux pas
faire ce genre de films une fois que tu as atteint un
certain âge et tu vas être moins
moins précis sur la façon dont ce genre
de  les choses sont dans la vraie vie, donc le
timing était parfait, le personnage était parfait
et euh
non, je suis vraiment reconnaissant et je suis
derrière et j'ai toujours
ce choix pour mon premier rôle principal